this question here falls under
coordinate geometry and
linear functions but one of the
peculiarities of this question
is that there are a couple of different
ways to solve it by virtue of the fact
that it's actually a multiple choice
question and we don't often think very
much about the fact that questions which
are multiple choice
actually have a few different techniques
available to them that aren't available
when you're solving an extended response
question where you've got to do all the
working
by yourself so i'm going to try and show
you two ways of solving this question
first i guess sort of what's a
traditional method uh
which you know i could use to solve this
even if it wasn't multiple choice
it's quite long as you'll see um
definitely more than one mark's worth
of working and so you can see because
there's a multiple choice but only worth
one so they're implying that there is
this other
kind of quicker sneakier way of working
it out without
having to go through the long path the
long path is required if you have to do
all the working
but here because you actually just have
options presented to you
a b c and d you can use that to take a
shortcut which is what i'll show you
second so first method long second
method
short let's have a go the line 3x minus
4y
plus 3 equals 0 is a tangent to a circle
with center three comma negative two
what's the equation
of the circle all right now to begin
with this longer method requires a few
bits of knowledge that you might not be
familiar with for starters you have to
know that when you've got
straight lines let's see here that's a
terrible
underline there this straight line here
is a tangent
to the circle so you need to know that
tangents to circles have a very
particular relationship when it comes to
their
angle tangents are perpendicular
to the radius of the circle at the point
of contact let me just quickly do a
drawing that shows you what that looks
like if i have a circle here
and then if i draw a tangent let's move
it so it actually
is touching because that's what tangent
means after all so here we go
that's more like it so if i've got a
tangent to the circle
and i relate that tangent to this
the radius rather of that circle at the
point of contact
something that you kind of need to know
for this long method of solving it
is that the radius and the tangent are
perpendicular at that particular spot
so we can then use a formula which you
also need to know
an extra piece of knowledge for this
particular solution method
i can now use something called the
perpendicular distance
formula the perpendicular distance
formula it relates a
point like the center of my circle here
with a line which in this case would be
our
tangent now the reason why that's useful
to me
is i know the equation of the tangent
it's uh given over here
i also know the equation of the center
it's right there
so the only other thing i need for the
equation of the circle
is the length of the radius how big is
this circle
so this is the unknown that i'm looking
for and the perpendicular distance
formula
it will give us that exact distance so i
can just substitute that in
use it to find the radius and then form
the equation from there
so let me show you how that solution
method works
firstly you need to know that a
perpendicular distance formula that i
mentioned before
and it's a bit a long and awkward one so
it looks like this there's an absolute
value because it's a distance
and i'll explain what each of these bits
of algebra
mean in a second absolute value of all
of that stuff on the numerator
divided by the square root of a squared
plus b squared which you might recognize
has something to do with
pythagoras's theorem because it does in
terms of the derivation which you don't
have to worry about for now
that is where it comes from so what's
going on here on the numerator you can
see
a b and c what those correspond to
are the a b and c in the general form
of the equation of the straight line
that you're interested in so in this
case
that straight line is 3x minus 4y
plus 3 equals 0. so our
a would be here it'd be three our
b would be here negative four and then
our c will also
be equal to three so that's a b and c
what um what is the the x one and the y
one you might be able to guess
that x one and y1 in there they
represent
the coordinates of the point that you're
interested in remember the perpendicular
distance formula
it works out the distance perpendicular
distance
between that straight line and this
point so the x1 y1
are the coordinates of that point so
being that my center of my circle is 3
comma negative 2 that means that my
x1 will be 3 i'm getting a lot of 3s in
this question
3 of them in fact and then my y1 will be
negative 2.
so now that i've identified all of the
pieces i can go
to my formula and see what it lands me
with so
what i got here absolute value of and
one of the handy things about the way
this is set up is i actually just write
out
more or less this equation in here
there's the a
then the b and then the c but instead of
writing x and y
i write x one and y one which are which
are these two coordinates here
okay so let's have a go and see what
result we get i'm going to go with
here three outside of x
one and then my b i think we said was
negative
four outside of y one which is negative
two double negative there gotta watch
out
plus three was um value c again
big old fraction line across here and
then the square root of
3 squared plus 4 squared you can see
this question
gave us some nice numbers but it didn't
have to it could have given us a certain
and would still be workable
let's start to evaluate this thing at
the top so absolute value of
9 double negative cancels so 4
times 2 gives us 8 plus
3 that's all divided by now i'm going to
get the square root of 9 plus 16 because
i've done this with pythagoras theorem 8
million times
i know that's the square of 25 so i'll i
know in a second that's going to
simplify out
up on the top there everything i'm 8 and
3 are all positive so i can somewhat
disregard
that absolute value now so that will
give me 20
on the top square root of 25 is 5
and so i'm getting 4 as my answer so
that distance happens to be the radius
of the circle that i'm interested in so
now what i can do is i can say
i have all the information that i need
to work out the equation of the circle
i can say the equation is
because i know that a circle's form is
generally
x minus h plus y
minus k squared both of them are squared
i should have said that
which equals r squared where h comma k
are the coordinates of my s
the center of the circle and i have both
of those so therefore i can
substitute into this formula i can say
it's x minus 3
squared plus y and then i'm going to
take away negative 2
which is plus 2. that's squared and then
i get
4 squared which of course is 16 and i
have a look at that
i check it against my options here and
you can see
it's the last one which is why in fact
that is what is marked as correct
so that was a way to find out the
solution but it was definitely
the long way around and you needed to
know some stuff about circle geometry
you needed to know this this formula
here the perpendicular distance formula
so that's that's not the preferred way
of doing this
what is a cheaper and easier way which
we can get to this answer
well the first thing i want you to do is
look closely at these multiple choice
options and this is an important
multiple choice
strategy that is often very very
applicable and will save you a lot of
time
we already know what the right answer is
but i wonder if you realize that even
before i started doing any working
just by looking at the information
provided to us in the question
i could already have eliminated a couple
of the choices
i could go from four options down to two
think about this
up here i need to make this a bit bigger
let's make that one there we go
up here we got given the eq sorry the
coordinates of the center of the circle
three
comma negative two now i didn't need to
do any working with that
to put it into the equation of a circle
down here i was just
substituting into the equation of a
circle given that this was my value of h
and this was my value of k now i can do
that immediately
and get x minus 3 all squared plus y
plus 2
or squared so i straight away know some
of my options
are you know not going to be relevant
for example you can see
here this top one here the signs are
backwards you know instead of getting -3
plus 2
i have them the other way around so that
one's incorrect
and i can see that option c has the same
problem it's also
you can see here plus 3 and minus 2. so
i'm going to get rid of that
as well so immediately i've gotten down
to b
and d and if you look at them closely
the left hand sides are identical it's
the right hand sides
that are different so one of them has
that radius
of 4 so 4 squared gives you 16. we
already know that's the answer
the other one here if i've got r squared
on the
right hand side and equals 4 then that's
suggesting to me that the radius would
be
2. so now i'm trying to tell the
difference between
is it circle b which has a radius of 2
or is it circle d which has a radius of
4. now we can actually work out very
quickly and easily
which one of these it is with the aid of
a simple
sketch so let's have a go at doing it
like so
i'm going to move these guys out of the
way for a second we'll use this space
that's just available here
i'm going to draw the line that is
tangent to the circle
i'm going to put in the coordinate and
i'm going to show you how very quickly
you can see that just those two pieces
of information
will tell you whether it's the small
circle or the big circle
for starters just really quick i'm going
to take this equation which is in
general form
and i'm just going to put it in a form
that's easier for me to graph you don't
have to do this but maybe you would find
it
simpler as well if i have that 4y term
if i add it to both sides i'll get
4y equals 3x plus 3 and then accordingly
if i put that into
slope intercepts form i'm going to get y
equals three quarters
x plus three quarters now the reason why
i like this form is i can immediately
work out very roughly what this thing
looks like
um i can say if i just draw myself up
some
corner axis here real quick
i can say why is that not locking in
that'll do
there we go i can say that it's going to
have i'll do it in a different color
just so it's easier to see
it's going to have a gradient of three
quarters so instead of a gradient of
one which is up at 40 degree 45 degrees
it's a bit shallower than that
and i can also say that it passes
through the y-axis
at three-quarters because i get that
from from here right
so if i call this my tangent line call
that one
three-quarters right there now if i pop
in the center of the circle as well i
can say well if it's a three at negative
two i'm going to use the scale that i've
just put onto here right
so if that's three quarters right there
then one must be just a little bit above
it
and that means 2 would be double that
distance so if we call that 2
then going in the opposite direction
that gives you negative 1 negative 2
about there and then you can see i need
to go over to the right 3 units
1 two three again keeping my scale
consistent
i'm not even ruling this but it's still
close enough for me to answer this
question very quickly
that's three so there's three comma
negative
two now you can imagine right like and
you don't even have to draw it but if
you were trying to say oh i'm going to
fit a circle onto here and needs to be
big enough
bigger than that needs to be big enough
to be able to reach over to that tangent
line right
you can immediately see now hopefully
that as you're trying to
reach over to there a distance of two a
radius of two is not going to cut it
because a radius of two it corresponds
to this distance in here you can see
that's from zero
to negative two so even just going
straight up and down right like
this oopsie daisy i've written another
color just to highlight it
that distance there is two so you know
if i was going on the diagonal one
would not go quite as far i'm not even
close and this is
a very rough sketch but you can already
tell that this has the same
purpose it serves the same function of
getting rid of one of my answers it
can't possibly be a radius
of 2 because it wouldn't be a big enough
circle so even though i don't know
off of this what the precise radius is
which is what the longer method showed
us like so
i can eliminate this option too so
therefore um the radius has to be four
and that's another way of doing this
and honestly it would have been quicker
than me um describing it to you because
i would have just drawn a rough sketch
and i would say oh okay if i had a
circle radius two would be something
like this
can't be it i'm going to choose the last
remaining option it just took me a while
because i was talking through every step
so i hope that makes sense it is a bit
of a sneaky question i would not
recommend that longer path even if you
do know enough stuff to do that
because you're just chewing up time that
is not necessary especially in the
multiple choice section